14 postseason victories underneath this
man long time baseball front office man
at real Ned Colletti on Twitter good to
see you ned absolutely this part of the
reason why I love this job is I get to
be people like you and I'm thinking to
myself you know when I know you're
coming in on my autumn ask about this
I'm asking about that and I will ask you
this in that but you just strolled here
Brockman
from from the greenroom couch right next
to you you were holding the baseball bat
the Billy Wyatt baseball bat that Mark
Harmon gave us because that's the bat
that he had on the set of stealing home
he autographed at Jodie Foster who was
here last month autographed it and then
you said what about Mark Harmon
there's no Mark Harmon I know 30 years
Rick Sutcliffe and Barry at Wright who
is Rick's agent introduced me to mark
and we put on Mark's bachelor party for
wedding before he married Pam Dawber
like I don't know 30 years ago Mark
Harmon is one of the best ones any walk
alive so you and Rick Sutcliffe put
together mark Carmen's bachelor party
before he married the actress who played
Mindy of Mork & Mindy that's right
Axelrod was the agent for both so Berry
was really in the middle of it is there
anything more you could tell us about
that bachelor party you know as you get
older your memory starts well Sutcliffe
is one of my favorite people I've ever
met in sports I loved I did a I did a
play-by-play on ESPN with him on a July
4th it was a Dodger game in st. Louis I
did it would suck LIF it was like riding
in a rolls-royce he's so great at what
he does and the stories are unbelievable
I love Chuck LIF I know you know those
street people have been friends of mine
for a long long time Rick Barry and Mark
and they are so good at what they do and
just just good people yeah and they do
have a story or two that's just ones
that can't be told right here so um why
are all these trade deadline trades
being done well before the deadline you
know I think baseball is in a different
spot than it's ever been I think when
you look at how many teams are gonna
lose 90 games you're maybe eight or nine
teams lose 90 games and maybe three or
four lose a
games they have no reason to hang on and
wait for July 31st mmm their downside is
injury you're making 18 million a year
you're making about $100,000 a day so
why not save an extra million here or
there if you can get the prospects you
want you make them move the parity and
baseball there is the very rich as far
as wins the very poor as far as as wins
and lost so what about money is there a
level playing field or I think the old
small market mid market big markets and
I think that you know the the way it's
set up it has helped it should have
helped parity but I think if teams get
into no-man's land where they're
spending a hundred million let's say or
a hundred and ten million on payroll and
it may win 75 games
what would you win 75 games spend a
hundred hundred and ten million dollars
when you could spend seventy million
dollars and win ten fewer games and live
in my world if you don't win what are
you doing you know I mean your ever
entertained no doubt but winning is part
of entertaining so there are some teams
that that are looking more to bottom
line than a standings do you thought
about that I think I think the if you
can't win if teams realize you're not
gonna win I don't think they're gonna go
deeply into into a payroll situation I
think they'll hold it off and they'll
wait until their farm system starts to
develop and they have a chance to win
you look at Philly you look at Milwaukee
you look at Atlanta right now good young
teams on the up-and-coming Houston was
the same way Houston was losing 100
games a year for a while so teams
there's no it's like strikeouts nobody
worries about strikeouts everybody the
strikeouts are cool even though the time
we're in Little League strikeouts were
like the the black flag you know and and
losing is the same way if you're not
gonna win teams aren't afraid to lose
Ned Colletti here in the Rich Eisen show
mike rizzo general manager the Nationals
who you know yes okay said this when
asked by Joel Sherman of the New York
Post if there was any scenario in which
the Nationals would trade Bryce Harper
who's a free agent
his response quote something extreme
would have to happen for us to consider
moving him so that you know the Dumb and
Dumber phrase that you're saying there's
a chance he's saying there's a chance in
that what do you think that means I
think it would have to be something
overwhelming for them to trade Bryce
Harper they've had a tough year I've
known Mike Rizzo a long time we grew up
at miles from each other
back in Chicago almost went to the in
the same high school conference baseball
players he at 51 and 51 they had great
expectations this year and they're in a
tough spot they're chasing Philly
they're chasing Atlanta he knows this
team better than anybody and if he
thinks that it's time to sell off
whether it's bullpen or whether it's
it's the big guy that's that's the
bullpen is one thing the big guys a
major decision so the big guy what needs
to like what is the extreme prospects
that you didn't think that you could get
or one of those phone calls as they said
in the old movie and oh dear you cannot
refuse you're the Godfather do ya you
get a call from somebody and the names
you're hearing you know you can't put
the phone down and it would probably
take that type of deal to get braces so
we saw what he did on the home run derby
stage and it was awesome I was there I
was there with my kids my kids went nuts
and I also saw what the Nationals fans
did in response to him and obviously
he's got a bond there but has he lost
himself some money
it's of what's happened this season when
it all comes around he still Bryce
Harper he still Bryce Harper he's still
a great player he's still one of the
youngest free agents in the history of
free agency when you think about it and
so there is a lot of cachet to that but
again he have a lot more cash if he was
hitting 302 inthis same thing you know
but it's the free agent here is a tough
year for some people and it affects
everybody a little bit differently and I
don't know you know I don't know Bryce I
know Scott Boras who represents Bryce
for a long time so I don't know all the
dynamics of it but I do know that tip
this is a very atypical year for a very
good player this happens to be his walk
here what do you think about the
possibility of a rental for for Harper
from I'll just throw it out there the
craziest rumor I heard was Oakland what
do you think is that a possibility well
anything's a possibility but when you're
trading somebody of that magnitude and
you have expectations and I know it's
going to be a free agent but there's so
many conversations that take place that
you and I are not aware of we don't know
exactly where the learner family is and
Mike Rizzo is with Scott and Bryce
Harper there may be all sorts of
conversations that leads them into a
direction that they're both going to
follow we now and the end of the
the free-agent period but I think that
it would take something huge to move
Bryce Harper at this point so Adam Jones
is that I guess the biggest name that's
left there to go what do you what do you
think is going on in the front office of
Oakland where all of a sudden Wow
something special is potentially
materializing but they still have the
finances of that stadium and they might
be thinking about Portland who the heck
knows but while all that's happening
there
they're materializing into a threat here
but 18 over right now Willy bean and
David force every few years this happens
for them I know and they build and they
build and they kind of sit in the weeds
a little bit last time that happened
they went and got Lester when she
shocked a lot of people on going for him
as a rental so we'll see what they do
but they're you know they're very smart
I've known Billy for ages what do you
think they're gonna do well I think
though if they can and I think they
won't I think they understand where
they're at too in that market they need
a new stadium they need to really bite
revitalized a market they've been
competing against the Giants for decades
for a long time the Giants had the new
ballpark but no World Championship
suddenly the Giants got a new ballpark
and three World Championships and
Oakland it's kind of sitting there
trying to figure out how good they're
gonna be and what were they're gonna
play and the Raiders are missing the
Warriors are going across the bay this
is a big time for the Oakland A's yeah
it would be I mean it's amazing what
they've what they've done and how how
this is materialized I mean they're
right they're right behind Seattle the
game behind Seattle oh yeah baseball
season you can't fool it you can catch
the best team in the American League
still is who Houston
I think Houston in Boston I think those
two teams but Houston I think is the
best team they've added good players
they've had a good pitching they
continue to get stronger
Erin judge off for three weeks that one
hurts
that's what's gonna tell the tale teams
right now we're talking about the
trading deadline yeah I think the teams
by and large for the most part eighty
percent of them they're trading for the
month of October they know they're gonna
get there barring a lot of crazy
injuries they know they have a
confidence they're gonna get there but
they're trading really for an October
type of situation but a lot of the
things that'll happen between now and
October 1st
injuries to a guy like judge other
injuries that will happen in the next
two plus months that'll tell a story too
don't take a break come back talk
Machado short and long-term what you
think that's the play right here in Los
Angeles and whether you think that the
Dodgers are in fact the team to beat as
the man who did tell me when you were
last year and mate chill out there's
still lots more games to be played it's
not nowadays small month I'd suggest
baseball season of the baseball month
baseball man Ned Colletti here on the
Rich Eisen show a Hall of Famer Jim
Kelly still to come on this busy Friday
we've got Ned Colletti here on the Rich
Eisen show how much of a difference
maker is Manny Machado in your
estimation you've got a very good team
that Ed or one of the best players is
going to get traded if not the best
player that's gonna get traded this
trading deadline Manny Machado
tremendous hitter tremendous defender
can play two positions saw some of the
other day against I think Philly tripled
and typically when I when a base runner
in this era is running towards second
base he'll glanced over his shoulder to
see where the right fielders doing he's
got a third base coach down there but
they kind of glanced lose his step
no he understood he understands how to
play and he's on third base as a short
short flyball to centerfield most people
are not gonna try it and score on a
sacrifice fly in his play he makes up -
about 10 feet 10-15 feet full speed
watching the outfielder Herrera juggles
the ball just a second in the glove just
at split second he's off and running
he knows how to run the bases he knows
how to hit he knows how to field he to
me he is one of the most complete
players in the game today and one of the
best players of this year and another
young free agent yeah well is he gonna
be a free agent do you think or do you
think the Dodgers what's their what's
their plan right now I think he will be
a free agent that doesn't preclude
Nevada's from signing up my course when
you wait this long you're gonna see what
the market will bear and he's got yous
done nothing wrong except to continue to
increase his market Dodgers get to
October which very likely they're going
to suddenly that stage changes for him
too and the value of a player who is a
great player from April till October and
then a great player in the month of
October that's off the charts so let's
let's then let's go ahead and and and
get the ultimate Valhalla scenario here
for
Dodger fans he helps lead the Dodgers to
win it all first time since 1988 how do
they not resign him right how do they
not and if that's a rhetorical question
how do they work the roster to keep him
who moves with well that's that's the
big question because you got Justin
Turner a third yeah and you've got
secrecy coming back it's short nose are
two spots Manny Machado plays one of
those two players is gonna have to have
a drastic switch in order this in order
to have Manny Machado play the left side
of the infield so I'm not sure how that
really works just internal when I sign
him was more of a utility infielder
could play a lot of different places was
a little bit of a younger player then
playing second base is not like playing
third base so you've got a different
dynamic there you move somebody to first
base at some point time I move Bellinger
to the outfield but then they've got max
Muncie who's really played well there's
a lot of moving parts so these are these
are first-rate first-class problems oh
yeah these are the problems you hope to
have rather than looking around and
going who's gonna play what's your best
guess my best guess is hey they may wait
another year and see if somebody else
comes free so let Machado walk well see
how it goes I mean we don't the beauty
of sports is everyday it's like a
kaleidoscope it changes to picture just
a little bit we're not sure exactly
what's gonna happen today let alone
three months from today but I do think
it's gonna be an interesting dynamic I
think he is in such a good place for him
and the Dodgers are in a such a good
place with him that'd make them a team
to beat me and you know I don't have any
doubt I don't I don't see I watch a lot
of games the way they hit pitching to me
has been mediocre it's been below
average in the league for a while they
are so patient they make a pitcher throw
a strike they go want to know to know
put themselves in a hitter's account and
then they do damage and they do they run
through pitching staffs and the flipside
their pitchers exploit hitters
weaknesses as good as anybody they've
got the best combination going I don't
know that there's a national league team
that can pitch to this lineup I'm not
there maybe a nationally team that can
score off the Dodger staff hmm but I
don't know that there's a rotation and a
bullpen out there that can dominate the
Dodgers hitters
what about Hamels with the
now you know what I sat there and I
watched them dominate Dodgers in oh wait
no nine we played them in LCS I sat
there and grimaces I watched him and
Chase Utley and Rollins and Howard and
Victorino and those guys do damage to us
he's not the same guy to me he has had a
tremendous career he'll still be able to
pitch a great game here in their five
starts one will be terrific three will
be average maybe a tick below and one
month one you'd like to forget so he's
not you're not you're not acquiring Cole
Hamels from 2008 2010 or when Texas
acquired him a few years ago very
serviceable somebody goes down you got a
big Lee starter who knows how to pitch
but to expect him to carry the Cubs
rotation along with Lester to the
promised land I don't see it and then
you got obviously the Yankees adding
Britain and Happ hoping that you know
those those are two arms that can help
them get ahead of the the Red Sox I mean
this is amazing that the Yankees are 29
games above 500 and they're four and a
half out oh yeah
Red Sox have been terrific it's a it's
an interesting dynamic as you also have
teams in that division that are trying
to win their 30th game Baltimore with 29
Kansas City has 31 they're taking on the
Yankees tonight you got you got three or
four teams are gonna lose 100 again it's
unbelievable good to see you sir
pleasure always oh you're welcome here
anytime we'll get you back in thank you
you know in the neighborhood as you said
it's a baseball season not a baseball
month write that one down I like I like
that where'd you get that is that the
one that Sutcliffe gave miss Lovelace
one of our scouts there was his line
whenever I started to get like you bet
on April I start pay city good
boss it's a baseball season that a
baseball month Jim Kelly when we come
back the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience